现在谈的这个对象就是说要不要结婚，
或者说结婚以后应该用什么样的心态去跟他相处，
你今年多大了？
我今年33，
之前有过婚姻吗？
在农村办过那种酒席，
但是没有领证，
那十几年前了，
没有领证，
就是没有结婚，
在法律上农村嘛，
他就属于结过婚的，
然后我对象的话，
他比我小七八岁，
他是做什么的呀，
我们两个都是做游戏方面的，
就陪以玩呀，
带练啊，
就种你在农村办的那个婚礼啊，
后来跟他是为什么分开呢？
两个人有小孩吗？
没有，
当天结完第二天我就走了，
那会儿就想着家里面开心就好，
然后就觉得那你爸爸妈妈对你怎么样啊，
爸爸的话不管家里的事情，
妈妈的话心比较偏向哥哥家吧，
就是我们家是三兄弟吧，
像有个哥哥和弟弟，
他们都结婚了，
就是晚自习了，
嗯，
妈妈是比较重男轻女的，
他也不算重男轻女吧，
就以前家里就那种欣想吧，
他现在对我蛮好的，
现在比你小七八岁的这个男孩儿，
你俩是怎么认识的呀？
就是同行啊，
就是说我们做这个事情嘛，
然后有一些关联吗？
不认识，
那你见过他爸爸妈妈了吗？
见过他爸妈怎么样啊？
第一次去见的时候，
他爸爸做了挺多饭。
呀，
那些，
然后他们对我感觉也挺重视的，
有矛盾的点是因为那个彩礼是我自己那个婚前的东西要公证，
就是提到的时候他的第一反应都是否定，
然后有点大男子厨艺吧，
跟他爸爸一样，
不接受我公证，
你自己现在攒下来多少家产啊，
有两套房全款的，
100多吧，
两套房全款加起来有100多万是吧？
对，
一个是公寓，
一个是小厨宅，
全款的话十几二室，
那很棒，
这两套房如果是你全款就在婚前买的，
不公证也没关系，
从法律上来说的话，
它就是你的婚前个人财产，
即便是有一天你要跟他分开，
这个两套房她是一毛都分不走的，
公账也行是吗？
你的存款的话也是不用公账都不用写是吧？
存款呢，
龙菲姐教你一个方法，
你呢，
去重新办一张卡，
比如说啊，
你有建行的卡了，
对不对，
你重新办一张农行卡，
你这张农行卡你不用干别的事儿，
你只用于存你自己的婚前存款，
你给他存定期也好，
活期也好，
都没有关系，
然后这张农行卡你不要绑定你的微信支付宝，
不要让他有什么流水，
有什么支出，
然后以后你赚的钱呢，
也不要放到这张农行卡里面，
像农行卡只用来办一件事情，
就像一个碗一样，
只。
装婚前的那个存款，
不干别的事情，
你这个存款就是从法律上来说的话，
还是你的婚前个人财产啊，
在将来要是分手的话，
是分不走这20万的，
那我的房子他有可能要卖吗？
因为我现在在卖吗，
但是他有点亏钱，
所以我先租出去的，
如果房子要卖的话，
这个房子在签合同的时候啊，
就写明白说这个房子呃，
卖了之后打钱要打到哪张卡里，
也打到这张农行卡里，
那你有卖房子的合同，
有打款的记录，
才能证明这个农行卡里的这个钱，
举个例子说，
卖了80万哦，
这80万的钱是从你自己婚前的这套房变过来的，
这个80万还是你个人的，
即便是将来你跟他要分手的话，
他也分不走你这个房子卖出来的这个钱，
主要你需要注意的就是你自己结婚之后用的卡和这张农行卡不要去转账，
不要有任何的关联，
知道了吧？
嗯，
其实我还纠结一个点，
之前就是刚在一起的时候，
给我花了应该有两三万块钱吧，
就是半年的时间，
然后他就去跟人家说是给我转账找了十几万，
然后又跟他爸妈说我的新房子的家具啊什么的，
他都买了很多什么的，
就有点特别催他的那种感觉。
比较年轻的时候嘛，
家里存的钱给他拿出去给亏掉了，
亏了100个吧，
他就每天就说里，
他说我能亏100个，
我也能赚回来，
感觉他有点太自大了吧，
我感觉关念不是很一样，
就但是我就觉得他们对我确实还蛮好的吧，
然后我想着我说到底要不要结婚，
假如结婚的话，
应家用什么样的心态，
就是跟他好好处呀，
或者怎样的，
现在你们两个人的谁的收入高一点呀，
差不多吧，
他的收入的话，
有一部分是我给他的那个9元，
嗯，
大概一年能挣多少钱呀，
十个是有的，
个人觉得啊，
姑娘你如果说在33岁的年纪，
自己能攒下来两套全款的房子，
还有20万的存款，
就是你本身是一个非常有规划的，
脚踏实地的一个女孩儿，
但是你的现在比你小七八岁的这个男朋友，
她25岁是吧，
她如果说能够去刻意的放大自己对家庭的贡献，
放大对你的大方程度，
也就是说他是一个很好面子的人，
他希望外界对他的评价，
他是一个大方的是吧，
就是有钱的，
有能力的这样一个人，
他那个老死很好面子，
就因为做公作这件事情，
他爸爸就也挺那个好面子，
就觉得很丢人，
就觉得让我说不要做了，
我为什么想连麦，
是因为最近吵，
之前也吵过几次，
吵的时候他就嗯。
分手嘛，
分手的时候，
然后我就说把钱还给他，
但是他会夸大那个钱嘛，
然后我就后来他就老求和，
悄悄分手，
但是没有分掉，
一直在求和，
然后他妈妈也经常给我打那个视频，
发微信，
过节的时候还给我发红包什么的，
我感觉现在他们都挺好的，
就是这个男孩子有点就是可能不太成熟吧，
然后最近一次吵的时候，
嗯，
是因为有个4000块钱，
他说他身上没钱了嘛，
因为为了准备我们结婚这个事情，
准备彩礼啊，
三金啊五金啊那些东西，
然后他之前跟我借了4000块钱，
他就一直没有还嘛，
然后有个事情就是我弟弟嘛，
嗯，
出了点事情，
然后他父母还借了4万块钱，
我就觉得他们家确实挺重视的，
都还没结婚呢，
都能借4万块钱给我弟弟去解决他的问题啊，
然后我弟弟呢，
也还他们钱了，
然后最后还差2万块钱没还上，
然后这个男朋友呢，
他也差我一万六，
然后我就说让我弟弟再给他6000块钱，
他就觉得我不应该把这个4000块钱放到我弟弟那边去，
然后就因为这个事情吵起来，
在他的眼里的话，
他觉得你弟弟欠的钱是该还的，
而你和他之间是一体的，
他不应该把这两个账算到一起，
对，
他也是这样说的，
他说我跟他算的太清楚了，
因为他给我两年也花了有小10万块。
钱吧，
然后他觉得我不应该为了这个钱，
然后我当时我就感觉我可能是身在其中吧，
我有点反应不过来，
反正我就觉得他借的钱就是借了我这样吵起来，
其实他的那个想法我觉得是没有什么问题的，
从或者从人和人的关系，
亲除远近上来说的话，
如果你俩是夫妻关系对吧，
那么你弟弟和他的爸爸妈妈之间的这个债权债务，
那是另外一回事儿，
你俩之间是另外一回事儿，
他有这个想法我倒是挺能理解的，
他故意夸大他对你的付出，
故意夸大这个东西是一个很不好的一个信号。
还有就是他说他亏了他爸爸妈妈100多万，
他说他能亏也能赚，
实际上你认为他真的有这个能力吗？
嗯，
他这两年刚做这个，
做我这一行，
我给他做的早一些，
他这两年赚的钱其实也有几十万吧，
不少，
其实我自己内心的想法是，
就因为我年龄偏大了嘛，
然后这个人刚好也是我们老家这边，
就是离得家里比较近，
所以我才选择他的，
因为我只要33岁了，
如果我再小一点的话，
我想着我应该会换一个，
所以我现在纠结的是我要不要跟他走进婚姻，
就是按现在这个年龄来说的话，
就是如果我走进婚姻，
我应该用什么样的态度啊？
要不要走入婚姻啊？
我先问你一个问题，
你喜欢孩子吗？
喜欢，
但是不是很想听这个回答，
让我就该怎么聊了，
你喜欢孩子，
你不想生，
其实我想说的是，
如果你本身啊，
对生孩子这个事儿没有什么焦虑，
就是你谈恋爱谈到多大都可以，
但如果说你想要孩子的话，
33岁这个年纪也确实是到坎儿上了，
对，
就是卡着这个点了，
所以我就比较焦虑嘛，
那我要是跟他结婚的话，
我就是说我应该用什么样的心态，
就是能更好的相处，
如果你想要跟他结婚啊，
你用什么心态跟他好好的相处呢？
就是接纳他要面子这一点以后，
在人前人后要维护他的自尊，
维护他的面子，
如果说他的爸爸妈妈对你还算大方，
对你还算好的话，
就尽量跟他的爸爸妈妈去打好关系，
他妈妈目前是比较偏向了，
他姐姐也是。
啊，
然后还有一点的话，
婚前财产的那个公证大可不必，
没有必要签，
因为你的这种情况，
通过龙飞律师讲的这个方法，
不签公证也能够实现保护你的财产，
那么如果以后想离婚，
难道还会敲诈勒索，
我其实我也担心这一点，
就前段时间刚吵的，
然后他有提到出行的话，
就是说，
嗯，
让我退他10万块钱，
这些钱也不完全是我一个人花的，
也有他花的钱，
他觉得亲属卡吗？
就是说假如我不跟他在一起的话，
我到时候要还他钱，
应该还哪些呢？
嗯，
如果你不跟他在一起，
你需要还的钱是那种以结婚为目的的，
赠与以结婚为前提条件的财产上的，
比如说给你的彩礼，
给你大额的这个转账，
这个是需要还的，
那如果说你们共同消费掉的，
你们共同租房子呀，
共同生活开销啊，
消费掉的可以抵扣掉，
那亲除卡那种就不用了，
是吧，
那像支付宝微信，
还有那个亲密卡，
最少亲密付，
他每个月给你多少额度，
如果说这个亲密付是用到你们两个人吃饭呀，
看电影啊，
买衣服呀，
买鞋子呀，
是用到这些方面的话，
他是呃退不回去的，
只有那种呃，
明摆着都给了你88000的彩礼，
给你转账转了2万块钱，
呃。
三金钱，
5万块钱，
什么五金钱，
这个是要退的，
明白了吧，
你到时候去评论区去看一看，
但那些过来人找一个这种大男子主义啊，
好大喜功啊，
特别要面子啊，
分手的时候要退钱啊，
而且分手的时候要退钱，
恨不得你你吃了几个西瓜，
他不能给你算出来这个西瓜值多少钱啊，
就那种的，
我大概猜到会有这些想法的，
就这些我能接受，
就是他每次他都会求我和好，
然后我主要是年龄这个问题，
嗯，
各方面很矛盾吧，
23岁这个年龄也还好吧，
嗯，
好，
谢谢谢谢拜。
彩礼什么情况下要退，
大概退多少，
这我以前啊，
工作的时候真的见过那种说啊，
你在我们家吃了几个饺子，
一个饺子多少钱，
你跟我分手了的话，
那么你在我家吃了这个饺子也得算多少钱，
见过那种，
嗯，
就是做了一个Excel表格，
这Excel表格里面写的是某年某月某日啊，
我给你点了一个外卖多少钱，
某年某月某日啊，
我给你买了一双拖鞋多少钱，
我俩一起去，
嗯哪儿，
就是吃了什么烤串，
我花了多少钱，
AA的话你该给我多少钱，
我真见过这个Excel表格，
我跟大家讲一下啊，
现在呢，
就是二零。
二四年的时候出了一个关于彩礼的这规定，
里面讲的是那些联络情感的特殊纪念意义的，
送的那些啊，
转的那些账啊，
那个一般情况下就退不回去了。
指的是什么呢？
比如说女方过生日啊，
过什么520啊，
七夕节呀，
那个时候你转账，
什么1314啊，
520啊，
就是这样类似的什么666啊，
888呀，
这种特殊纪念意义的状态下的，
买礼物也好，
转账也好，
通常都不被认定为是彩礼，
就就是为了增进感情，
一起共同去开销的，
什么吃饭啦，
旅游啦，
买机票啦，
订房间啦，
这些东西都不会被认定为是彩礼，
也不会退的，
怎么才会被被认定为是彩礼呢？
就是以结婚为目的的，
然后金钱上的给付，
比如给你转了六万六，
对吧，
这个就是彩礼了，
你要是不跟人结婚的话就得退，
比如他给你买的五金，
给你买的钻戒，
这些都会被认定为是彩礼，
不结婚的话，
那肯定得退，
就像刚才那个姐妹，
但是如果说你结了婚，
光领个证，
没有跟人家共同生活，
你光领了个结婚证，
然后你俩就分居两地，
没有共同生活，
然后过不多久的话，
你就想要。
婚又想要分手，
对，
那这种情况下的话，
那彩礼还是要退一部分的。
啊，
就就比较公平的嘛，
因为他给彩礼的目的不是说光领个证就结束了啊，
他给彩礼的目的是要跟你领证，
跟你过日子，
甚至跟你生儿育女才是他给彩礼的目的，
他这个目的条件没有达到的话，
那我跟你讲就是结婚时间特别短，
呃，
没有共同生育孩子很短暂，
你就要分开的话，
那还是要退一部分彩礼的啊。
再有一个就是如果情况相反，
你们虽然没有领结婚证，
但你们已经在一起共同生活很长时间了，
都已经生孩子了，
孩子恨不得都2岁了，
这个时候你想要退彩礼没门。
啊，
为什么？
虽然你俩没有结婚证，
但是你们已经具备了夫妻对吧？
实质的内容都已经具备了，
孩子都已经出生了，
孩子已经那么大了，
你想退彩礼没门儿啊，
就这意思啊。